je voudrais vous demander de quelle
région vous venez je suis originaire du
canada
vous vous demandez où ça j'imagine je
sais où se trouve le canada j'y suis
allé moi-même c'est beaucoup de voyages
pour un esclave salomone nord top est un
grand virtuose du violon
je suis né libre j'ai vécu à new york
avec ma famille serge avec ta mère avant
d'être trahi
enlevé et vendu comme esclave
à retrouver la santé je m'appelle
seulement je suis un homme libre et vous
n'avez aucun droit de monsieur strict
des pins à mener pour tes rien de plus
qu'un clandestin évadés et le serviteur
n'obéit pas à son seigneur
celui là sera battu par le fait de
nombreuses fois parole de marché la
condition de vos travailleurs
elle est abject la propriété où les noms
c'est avec fierté que non ça fait par la
nama doit disposer de sa propriété il ya
même pas dix jours j'étais avec ma femme
chez moi et toi tu me dis de renoncer à
tous si tu tiens à la vie ne fait et ne
dit que le strict minimum
je ne veux pas sûr je veux vivre
mais question de gâcher quelque chose
j'ai suivi les instructions ci vient
défaut le défaut était dans les
instructions nettoie bien compte amener
ici pour travailler autrement ça te
faudra 100 coups de fouet je sais ce que
c'est que de faire l'objet des
attentions du maître à son nom le
seigneur s'occupera d'eux comme ne
cessant pas
je vais stopper
jeanne succomberait par désespoir genre
efforts jusqu'à la partie des têtes être
libérés
j'étais un homme libre
je ne suis pas une esclave